hello folks welcome to rational science
got a great day today got my son here
with me
anyways
um yeah I'm gonna start with a couple
bit of news that came out this week and
one of them comes at the heels of what
we were discussing last week you know we
were talking about religion and God
and this what happened uh in one of the
news clips that I found
ah we're a news channel now yeah I kind
of like that what happened to these at
the top it's at the top I missed it go
ahead oh there it is I thought it would
lead up here he goes
and uh we have this pastor Reverend
Charlie the Southall and I guess he got
him for embezzling defrauding 900k
almost a million bucks so I think he's
going from the Chapel to the prison
and he comes at the heels of people like
Jim Baker who uh also put his hand in a
cookie jar and also up a woman's skirt
Jimmy Swaggart who also says he sinned
he was crying in front of his
congregation and lately we had uh Jerry
falwell's son uh Jeremy Falwell Jr who
uh specifically claimed that he watched
specifically watched how his wife made
sex with another man I guess he did
something well he watched so uh these
are the pastors these are the
representatives of God
and all I can say is I don't know what
they can teach me about morality you
know I think they have nothing to preach
um in other news also came out this week
that caught my attention is this and
that's a group that is suing Biden over
the National Archives trying to get the
JFK assassination records that have been
postponed at least twice now maybe a
third time
and um these people say you know there's
information that's being hidden from the
public and they want to see it and of
course a lot of that's going to be
redacted anyway so the question is
whether uh seeing any of that record
will make any difference in the opinions
of people
and the uh assassination of Kennedy at
least the bullets you know that is a
question of physics did the bullet come
from the front or did it come from the
back and of course uh very important
piece of evidence uh Kennedy's head
disappeared and so we don't have it
today and so
um all I can say is that you know
without that evidence it's very hard to
make an analysis of which way the bullet
went and all I can tell you is I don't
think the Russians or the Cubans
the stole at Kennedy said
stolen his head yeah yeah his head is
not there and one Theory out there is
that
um this policeman uh tip it uh if you
look at him he's got the same uh
features as Kennedy and so one of the
theories that maybe they killed Tippett
because
um you know they used his head and
that's the one that uh they did the
analysis at the naval base in Baltimore
but you know again theories until we
have the head we don't know what
happened we we don't at least we don't
know which way the bullet came from and
um all we have is speculation theories
and whatever okay without without the
evidence in this case in this case the
evidence has to be analyzed if we're
going to make a theory based on our
Theory of physics
okay uh Paul says why don't I talk more
about Extinction he says it is
interesting to talk about Extinction in
light of the current political situation
and the only thing I want to um and he
wants to suggest that I make it part of
a regular part of my show again
and all I can say is that the um
we we do have it as a on a regular basis
here I thought you talked about it daily
uh uh I tried to talk every week if I
possibly can but only if there is
something new in the in the news
something that affects the global
economy the uh war in Ukraine obviously
has some effect on the global economy
but uh what's the issue there the issue
is uh we don't know what the other side
is saying so there's a lot of
information that is missing it's being
censored that's one issue but the other
one is that you know we're not here to
um take sides or you know vote for
candidates or tell you vote for this guy
vote for that guy I'm not here so much
that we're not making also
recommendations like uh you know we
should raise taxes lower the interest
rate none of that you know we don't do
politics in the sense of recommendations
or taking sides the only purpose of
using any information from
um from the news is how it affects the
global economy which is the the
foundation of the extinction Theory I
guess a big reason why we don't really
pick sides is we kind of already made up
our minds that we're doomed
so there's no side that can really save
us in that sense so it's like what's the
point in picking sides
kind of comes down to that
nevertheless uh here are some issues and
again related uh to the theory itself
meaning the um economy the global
economy how this affects the global
economy and uh Bloomberg had this
article forecast for U.S recession
within year hits 100 in bloated Biden in
other words uh they're saying there's
going to be a recession uh within a year
and the question is whether that
recession turns into a depression or
maybe into Extinction you know the
question is how far will this research
how deep first and how far will it go
this recession assuming uh the
expectations of the economists are
correct and here's another bit of news
exxon's Exodus employees have finally
had enough of its toxic culture lots of
Employees leaving Exxon and the reason I
mention Exxon is there in the oil
business and just recently Mr Putin
expropriated about 4 billion four four
to five billion dollars worth of
um uh equities or or assets that the
Exxon had in Russia and I think Exxon is
going to look to see if they can sue
Russia on the international market but
the question that inter of interest to
me is you know is the fact that all this
oil that's being played around with by
the big powers and so many players out
there uh will have an effect on the
global economy as well for sure we're
going to be in deep trouble this year
because winner apparently is coming
early this year probably colder I don't
know
but uh oil is going to be missing gas is
going to be missing and the question is
uh whether there's going to be rationing
of the uh energy Supply actually when I
went to the theater like last week and
they're already playing ads of like
families you should save on energy this
year it would be very nice and they got
like they got that going on like a
national ad okay so that already and
talking about your part and turn off the
hot water [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
talking about Russia here we have a
problem uh Russia has a problem and it's
got a problem in population which is
another issue related to Extinction
Putin's uh War escalation is hastening
the demographic crash for Russia Russia
has been having many years now decades
uh where its population is dropping it's
um growth rate is falling and
um
so is another country very close in
population to it and very near to it
which is Japan okay these two countries
are in a uh you can say a free fall okay
they're they're as far as their
population is concerned and it's a
somewhat of a problem because you know
the way I look at it you need more
population in order to create demand and
these people are going to have problems
in demand internal demand at least and
they're Japan and Russia are a little
different than countries like in the
west and they differ in that they don't
have any immigration this is the problem
with Russia and Japan uh Europe has lots
of immigration a lot of it illegal
the United States has immigration Canada
Australia and so on a lot of these
countries have immigration but Russia
and China don't and Russia and Japan
well China I don't know I don't know
about China but you're saying that
they're lack of immigration is what's
hastening their yeah the fact that
everyone they're not having his kid
they're running out of having kids or
they're having less and less kids so the
products there's only going to be able
there's not going to be anyone to sell
to because there's also no one coming
from the outer out of the country that's
when the other one that you have to keep
in mind that Europe has the same problem
you know Italy Spain all these countries
their their population is falling but
they're making up for it I don't know if
completely but to some degree with
immigration a lot of it again illegal
they're bringing in consumers well some
of them come by themselves but in a way
they're they're importing consumers yeah
yeah yeah and and there's a difference
there between Western Europe and Russia
and Japan so keep that in mind it does
have an effect on the global economy
especially on the uh
localized economy in this case Russia
and Japan right
uh I thought says uh what do I have to
say about brexit okay what is the
connection you see between America and
brexit well
um we got to look at the fact that first
uh the United States tried to separate
England uh specifically England because
Scotland Northern Ireland and they kind
of have different plans but they wanted
to
um
get Great Britain out of the European
Union and he finally achieved that after
like three or four years of trying the
other thing you have to keep in mind is
that this war in Ukraine uh you know
just helped the United States conquer
Europe because now Europe depends uh
more on uh the United States
and it's important to note that because
I think this this was a long-term plan
of the United States the reason I say
this is that uh you had Greenspan Alan
Greenspan he was the head of the FED uh
some time ago and when the European
Union started forming and especially the
uh Euro became the the currency
um people like Greenspan not only am but
many in the United States uh they
predicted and they kind of wished and
they said it will happen that Europe the
European Union would eventually break up
so they were hoping for it in Great
measure because your European Union is a
competitor of the United States in the
markets out there and so now with the
Ukrainian War you know the United States
got a good foothold in in Europe because
now Europe is going to depend more
heavily on the United States for energy
supplies uh they receive them relatively
cheaply from Russia and now that's gone
and so
um you know this puts Europe in general
Continental Europe closer to the United
States in many ways and more dependent
on the United States
uh Germany wasn't pulling its weight and
I I don't know about France but I know
Germany wasn't pulling its weight in
NATO and in fact
um uh who was it uh Trump was so fed up
that he said we're going to pull our
ourselves from NATO and cut this
nonsense we're not going to do NATO
anymore and when Biden came in the
politics changed completely and in fact
quite the opposite happened now Germany
is putting more of the bill than it was
and is even helping Ukraine which is not
part of NATO with weapons and so on so
uh you can see what's going on as far as
Europe Europe has been conquered without
firing a shot
uh in fact Putin said that Western
Europe has lost its sovereignty okay uh
that was his uh his assessment okay
getting more into
um extension especially the extinction
of the dinos okay with the most
important or the most distinctions well
the the most famous Extinction I think
you would say the other one I would say
would be the Neanderthals you know but
and that's a background Extinction but
this was the number one massive stage
okay and here it is yeah well supposedly
and uh when Paul says in dinosaur
extinction one more hypothesis Logan
fellow's rights and Robin Fells uh wrote
this in 1956. he wrote this paper in
which he suggested that there could be
an extraterrestrial impact okay and he
said dinosaurs seem to have prospered
more rather than less after uh modern
vegetation appeared in the Cretaceous
does this have any Merit and he
continues as fellow says it seems to
contradict your idea but yet in the same
paragraph grab Runner suggests that lack
of plant food caused the extinctions
okay so
um we're referring to this paper and the
first thing I need to mention is that
love him fells like I said the other day
it wasn't the guy who came up with the
Extraterrestrial impact Theory okay and
I mentioned that the other day uh
LaPlace was one who talked about it at
the end of the 18th century that's 200
years ago okay and I mentioned this
article okay that was written by this
fellow in which he does a history of
extraterrestrial uh extinction theories
and so he went back all the way to La
Place and there was another Frenchman
other than George couvier Who uh I
mentioned him once I can't find him
again but I'm gonna get two if I can get
them but uh in the 18th century he was
probably the first one to suggest that
maybe all these animals the Mosasaur was
one of the first ones they found maybe
all these animals from way back when
maybe they didn't die in a um you know
when God uh had it rained for 40 days
and 40 nights he said maybe it was an
extraterrestrial impact so the
Extraterrestrial impact theory has been
around for 200 years Logan Falls The
Lovin Fells did not come up with it
neither did Alvarez and so the question
is what did Alvarez invent what did he
discover what did he come up with you
know and here's Alvarez okay he's this
is from his famous 1980 paper okay and
the one the list that you see on the
left uh that's uh the subject matter of
each of each one of the topics in his
paper they all relate to evidence none
of them have anything to do with an
Extinction Theory a mechanism the only
one that addresses the extinction
mechanism is by biological effects
there's only five paragraphs in there
these are three of them here and I'll
just read the most important part He
suggests first that a temporary absence
of sunlight would effectively shut off
photosynthesis and this attack food
chains at their Origins okay great so
that's very general yes he's just saying
impact uh blotted out the sun with some
dust out there and that would uh affect
the food chains especially you know
starting with with the plants great okay
so how did the the mice survive in other
words the little tiny
um mammals that were at the feet running
at the at the feet of the dinosaurs
right it says terrestrial vertebrates
did survive and they did so by feeding
probably He suggests right insects and
became vegetation meaning the dritas and
uh that was the fourth one of his very
concise very general
ideas of how the animals disappeared he
didn't say anything new and I like his
last paragraph I'll repeat that because
I thought it was a bundle of laughs he
says we will not go further into this
matter but we refer the reader to the
proceedings of the 1976 Ottawa meeting
on the Cretaceous tertiary extinctions
this volume reproduces an extensive
discussion among the participants of
what would happen if the sunlight were
temporarily turned off
okay so he's basically saying some
people elaborated on this before me so
don't so read them yeah in other words
he says you want to know how the
dinosaurs disappear go go to these
Ottawa 1976 conference and yeah you'll
find a couple papers or maybe one or a
bunch of them talking about what would
happen if sunlight were turned off
that's it he didn't deal with that at
all he's saying I don't know how they
disappeared I don't care let me show you
the evidence
so why because he was a mathematician
that's all he was uh Alvarez and of
course uh we're still waiting for the
theory what is the mechanism that got
rid of all the animals especially the
issue that the only issue that an
Extinction theory has to address which
is selectivity
how does Mother Nature Select uh to live
you know allow the mammals to live and
allow the dinosaurs to die how does it
allow the angiosperms to radiate and the
conifers to die in general to you know
uh decrease in in volume and in uh
varieties yeah doing that with an
asteroid is kind of and and it also I
say there's uh not only cell activity
but chronological selectivity how does
Mother Nature Select the old species of
plants and animals and allow the new
species to survive coincidence yeah no
it's a very intelligent asteroid that
smart one it says yeah I mean asteroids
are really bad one maybe disease because
you kind of explain selectivity with
disease maybe yeah yeah in other words
but see they don't say a disease they
say it's uh it's the food chain which is
correct but then the question how do you
affect the food chain in such a way that
you get rid of the old species and get
and allow the new ones to survive and
here we have the answer okay for those
of you who are interested we do have an
answer it's the Cretaceous terrestrial
Revolution and you can see that sometime
before the mid
um Cretaceous Period
uh what you see there is that the
angiosperms started taking over the land
and muscling aside all the conifers
including the ferns as well right but
the Conover is primarily and you can see
how how the Cretaceous uh was a period
in which the angiosperms gradually over
millions of years muscle decide the
plants that the dinosaurs and other
animals ate on land at least right and
this does tend to explain in great
measure why the dinosaurs disappeared
and why the mammals who what do we eat
we eat angiosperms right flowering
plants seed plants right uh why we
radiated not only did the plants
radiated but the animals that forged a
millions of years of relationship with
these plants they radiated as well and
that's why we're around it just seems
like the answer is right there but
everyone keeps reaching for are these
like extreme versions
they're just flashy or if they just
can't if they just can't fathom that
this is just the process they make for a
good Hollywood besides I mean you see
those yeah
what are they going to say that look the
plants gradually disappear so you stay
in a movie for a million years to see
how the plants disappeared no I don't
think so very boring but if you see the
Astros I don't know if that's the reason
or if or if people just can't fathom
that nature has built within it for some
reason this is a mechanism of Extinction
this Extinction process where it's like
not only do species have their time but
like single species but entire species
the entire food chains have their time
it's like okay it's time to go you've
you've overstayed your wealth people
don't people think no one no one
extended that that deafness to hold to
that level of of in fact they say the
following they say if the asteroid had
not come we'd still have the dinosaurs
in New York City yeah like they'd still
be around
just have their cycle like we have
individual yards like the virus is
pretty smart as I said an illness would
kill uh maybe yeah no I think the main
reason is that the suddenness if you
look at the layer of the rock you see
that the animals disappeared relatively
quickly maybe in a question of thousands
of years which is relatively quickly in
geological terms and it said this was
something happened so they think all
these are catastrophes because of that
that's too quick and again I think
people like catastrophe oh yeah it's
cooler yeah that's true then again I
mean
animal species eating cannibalizing is
also pretty cool like Soylent Green
okay silent green is made of
[Music]
beef okay let's move on to our subject
of today and that's a field what is a
field okay here we and uh we left off
the other day with our science critic
can you believe who criticizes the
scientific method unbelievable this day
and age yes for you
okay so this is what he said he said
there are some things like field there
are things like Fields so he thinks a
field is a thing seems completely
foreign to us but when you learn about
these things right it makes it easier to
understand what is happening yeah the
problem is that a field is not a thing
okay and uh so that's the first problem
we uh showed uh James Maxwell uh he
wrote uh this mid 19th century feel the
space in the neighborhood of the
electric and magnetic bodies in that
space there is matter in motion okay so
and there you see it on the right you
see
um in this case a magnetic field and you
can see as soon as you put the magnet
inside that tube all the iron filings
underneath the water gradually one by
one is being picked up and put closer to
the magnet that means there is something
in motion not necessarily in Megan okay
explain it otherwise gravity is well
this is Against Gravity essentially yeah
gravity would by that definition also be
matter in motion
yeah you're pouring out a bottle of
water gravity keeps pulling it out yeah
but it's not in motion okay but this is
okay gravity downwards uh even then
gravity is not really in motion
gravity is not in motion correct well it
is in a way hold it it is in a way
because what you have is the more and
more uh ropes as two objects as the
distance between two objects decreases
so in that sense there is motion of the
ropes not pulling but you have more of
them so you know where the the where did
all the ropes in the next frame of the
universal movie The Rope angle motion
that's an abstract in that sense uh
there is motion under at least under the
Rope model right yeah well even under
the a mass model you know because uh
what is nice well yeah yeah but I mean
the way they they look at gravity is
that mass pulls on mass how it does so
we don't know but there the distance
decreases that's again gravity is a
dynamic thing I think we've probably had
the observation of the two things
touching each other yeah how it does
that yeah well this is decreases we got
that far okay how buddy
okay and so just want to mention that a
field is uh something in motion and you
have to separate the something from the
in motion okay and here's an example
okay here's a Cascade Cascade and
ordinary speech is a noun it is not a
noun for the purposes of physics a
Cascade is not a thing water is the
thing Cascade is what water does okay so
we have to separate the thing which is
water from Cascade which is what water
does I guess it's a nullification of a
verb yeah but see we have to be careful
with that in physics because we cannot
use something which is a verb like orbit
or uh or uh motion moving
and turn the word motion into a noun not
in physics that's okay in ordinary
speech but not in physics
let's not move the water spiral let's
just move the water and you have to
learn the language of physics the
language of physics is different than
ordinary speech you cannot continue or
you cannot bring words
indiscriminately from ordinary speech
into physics and say well it's a noun in
ordinary speech so I'm going to use it
as a noun here now only objects can
serve as nouns in ordinary speech in in
physics uh you don't say like I always
give the example the orbit of Jupiter
that's not the way you say it in physics
you say Jupiter orbits Jupiter is the
noun orbits what it does you don't talk
about the orbit of Jupiter in physics at
least treating it almost in that case
you could but like with a lot of care
but you see a lot of this because like
the word orbit you know that's what
where the word orbital came from for the
electron orbital you know they turn this
orbit into a thing like a channel in
which the electron rolls up about that
is because when they talk about an orbit
moving
you can kind of understand what you're
talking about it used to go around here
now it goes around here but in physics
the better way of saying that would be
it was orbiting around here and now it's
orbiting around here instead of saying
the orbit move yeah and and that's a lot
of that's how a lot of these verbs
become nouns orbit became orbital and
field which was what matter in motion
became a thing yeah and so on and the
same thing happens with mass uh energy
as well uh people think mass and they
say well yeah it's a mess that's moving
you know the ball is moving they see the
mass is moving no no the ball is moving
mass is what it weighs it's a it's a
property of the object not you can't see
the property moved yeah
and energy is yeah and energy is the
same thing or the size it's hard to
really wrap your head around that it's
not that as an outsider you got to
understand so that's not really new
language it's just we're bringing it
back to what do we really mean because
it's not doing
is people get away with murder with
these moving Reds and stuff
okay uh so here's one fella and he uh
wonders about this word field okay he
says you can understand everything as
long as you introduce Spirits in other
words I said that saying yeah if you're
going to introduce Spirits into your
theory then you can explain anything and
the other person I don't know what the
other person can understand but you can
explain anything and so he says how did
the field how did I equate field with
spirit that was his uh concern and I'm
saying yes look every time
uh you use the word field you could just
as well have said spirit because you're
going to use it as like a joker and a
rummy game you're gonna put it in there
every single time that you need it you
just say oh the field didn't and you
fixed the problem it's like oh okay now
I understand you didn't understand squat
because all you did was introduce a
spirit into the spirit did it you know
and oh okay I understand now you know
it's
it's uh it's more or less like that but
I'm going to address a second comment as
well he said define said where does it
say that you learn about what is meant
by a field means that now you understand
everything and we're down what else is
there to learn or in short or does it
ever say in science that we're done and
that we've learned all there is to learn
well more like we've learned all that we
wanted to learn for the moment isn't
that a more accurate well someone has a
question
okay that's the way I see it uh here's a
let's say you have an equation right and
uh
uh you have some invisible intangible
entity out there right you don't know
what it is all you can do is see the
visible stuff touch the tangible stuff
but not the intangible invisible stuff
okay so in the case of gravity we don't
see the invisible intangible stuff okay
so we say it's the spirit that's how
they used to say it in the old days you
know traditional religions today we say
it more scientifically we say it's
energy
or it's the field you know it's not Zeus
anymore yeah Zeus changes name to energy
it's the god of mass the god of energy
now you know you know any of those yeah
and so or the field yeah and so the
question is
um what what if
the mathematicians are applying their
mathematics
to the wrong to uh and well the wrong I
guess that would be the best way of
putting it the wrong uh invisible
intangible mediator that mother nature
uses and here's an example okay uh here
we have ants okay those are the
particles and at the bottom you have a
little wave there that's the snake well
obviously you know if you think that
between two objects what's happening is
a bunch of ants are going from A to B
that's a little different if if you
guessed something else you'd guess that
maybe it was a snake that
um lay between two objects and was just
waving in situ okay so up and down in
situ if you're going to apply a an
equation you and you apply and you do a
study and you're gonna invent this
equation say okay I've got an invasion
an equation for ants and it turns out
that mother nature is not using ants
Mother Nature is using a snap take then
your equations are worthless
and that's more or less the situation
today in uh in mathematical physics what
the mathematicians have done for the
last three thousand years is apply their
equations to
um to particles okay so you know one
thing is for them to use particles
another one is for them to hit it
correctly and say oh it wasn't it wasn't
the uh a bunch of particles that were
flowing it was something else and it was
actually you know uh a snake that was
truly in place or people say a wave or
whatever you know a wave is different
than a bunch of particles in fact you
cannot reconcile particles with waves uh
not particles going straight versus
particles going up and down and waving
you know for whatever reason because
they would have to be attached to each
other in order to have this wavy motion
you know if some particles go up what
pulls them down and vice versa you know
why would the particles move up and down
if they're all discrete particles so you
would have to attach them somehow and
again if you're going to apply equations
you're going to invent the equation
Discovery equations or develop equations
for ants it turns out that mother nature
does everything with snakes well you
just wasted what 400 years of of
research that's what you did okay your
equations are worthless okay so that's
all I want to say and the case with a
field is like that if as Mr Maxwell says
a field is matter in motion we first
have to discover what matter exotic
matter right in this case invisible
intangible only tangible to the iron
filings but certainly not to us what an
entity could be moving in that area once
you figure that out once you have God's
eyes and you can see you know with your
mind what's in that region what is that
matter exotic matter that's moving in
there
the equation that's crazy not only the
equations are easy but you are at the
end of the physics you're at the end of
science for the most part maybe there's
some little thing out there that you
haven't discovered but for all practical
purposes it's the end of physics it's
the end of science we've had the
explanations for How the Universe works
so this fella has this notion which I'd
like to destroy that science is an
ongoing process of discovery that's not
what science is science stops I like
physics stops once we discover for the
most part how this universe works yeah
there are details you don't even have to
say for the most part you can take it
all away and say there's a certain way
the world the universe works in
chemistry biology physics pick one
and the answers are finite the questions
are fine at some point you know this is
exactly how everything works maybe not
you no no this is my point my point is
that you know people say well Bill how
do you explain this little thing here
and say I don't know let me get to that
yeah I mean it's like you know I didn't
even ponder it you know I never even
knew about the event so you cannot know
of all the
little things that are out there in in
science everything well that's a really
good question that brings up a really
good question the question is how much
um let's say real physics have you not
done because you've been busy trying to
tear down the corrupt Temple that
science has become oh yeah yeah yeah but
there's a lot of science you haven't
done yeah as far as this nitty-gritty
you kind of stopped developing your own
theories in a lot of ways well that's
where I have some other fellows who yeah
I mean that's kind of why you're doing
all these videos yeah such right so is
to get the main point to get the main
point out so that people can work on the
nitty
okay so windfall says he uh continues
with spirits and of course uh I replaced
a couple of his words right he says uh
Lawrence is the fourth I'll get it in
the same
Lawrence The Lawrence force is the force
on a Charged particle due to what
electric and magnetic Spirits a Charged
particle is in an electric spirit will
always fuel a force due to this Spirit
yeah we can replace the word field with
spirit because we have not understood
anything by replacing that word spirit
with the word feel so it wouldn't matter
at all if you just put the word x the
letter X there or the word Spirit or the
word feel we understood just as much we
have no idea what a field is especially
if you're going to treat it as a thing
when Mr Maxwell says it's not a thing
it's something in motion inside a field
a bunch of something's in motion make up
a field just like a bunch of something's
in motion make a plasma there is no
physical object called plasma plasma is
a process where something happens to the
atom ionization okay so uh there you
can't take a snapshot of plasma because
when you do you don't have plasma plasma
is defined as something in motion Hold
On by that same logic with that also
applied a gas and solids and liquids
where there's no such thing as a liquid
because it's really just atoms in a
certain State well what we say is that
you know in the case of plasma it's the
definition of the word plasma what does
plasma mean on the other hand the word
table you know we don't there's no
meaning to the word table you point and
say table because you name the object
yeah okay you're teaching the ET you're
teaching him your language in the case
of plasma we've got a different
situation it's a concept it's defined
as ionization ionization is a process
that's where the difference lies what
the states are the same thing because
they're essentially properties there's
no such thing as a solid that's just the
property that the atoms have yeah when
they're in a certain State yeah we're
not talking about that because uh that
that line of reasoning is known as
myriology you're looking at what
something is made out of and what it's
doing time
um what is it uh you know there's a Time
slices Etc we're not looking at that
we're saying look table is what I point
to you know that's an object but plasma
is not what I point to plasma some is
defined as something that is happening
so plasma is a verb not a noun not
enough for the purposes of physics
okay uh and here another fellow says a
field is a geometrical blah blah blah
blah blah of an Energy's interaction so
a field is an interaction well if a
field is an interaction it's a verb okay
there is interaction is is obviously An
Occurrence it's a phenomenon it's a verb
something in motion and so a field is a
interaction well no problem we know what
it is now it's a verb I mean but
everything so you can't say a verb move
well no but everything two is that oh
yeah that's true you can't say a verb
move but everybody kind of knows that
magnetism is a verb there's something
happening there when you see getting
them pulled they're pulling
and yeah it is weird for people to talk
about a field doing the pulling because
a field is usually a static concept as
far as I understood it yeah people think
it's a static concept but you can see
that when you put that magnet underwater
there's something going on there the
field is doing something to the iron
fountains it's not like it goes bloop in
one shot it's like pulling one at a time
okay so it's important to understand
that okay uh so uh because of these
Notions of field as an interaction we
went to qft Quantum field Theory see
originally in the 1920s 26 thereabouts
um they said look uh the world is
discrete particles and the particles
ain't particles particles is a concept
it's not a thing it's not a ball it's
not a little grain of sand it's a
concept and they if that notion evolved
and today they've really gotten rid of
it if you tell a mathematician that a
particle is like a discreet little ball
he'll say no you're absolutely wrong you
have no idea you have no clue so what is
it well here it is okay qft was invented
and now they deal with field Theory what
does field well field means that there's
what this web of interconnection
uh by Concepts I guess because
everything can affect something else at
a distance and they built this web known
as a field and then if you want to know
what a particle is the field vibrates
locally and that's what a field is what
a particle is a particle is really a
vibration a local vibration of this
extensive field that goes all the way to
the edge of the universe as the universe
has an edge we're talking about The
Ether more or less it's the same color I
thought it was exactly the same but you
could say it's exactly they don't use
that word no they they hate that word
but it is like uh one of Nobel prizes
says you know we
we deal with The Ether every day but we
don't call it that because it's taboo
right
okay okay so here you see what is a
Quantum field Theory it treats particles
as what excited States
the state is already not a noun well uh
well it is if you come to think of it a
state is wait till November there'll be
there he'll be a bunch of states that
are going to be excited during the
election they're going to be all excited
believe me and excited
I feel like they just don't want to use
objects the artists well it's not a
particle it's not a thing because they
call that philosophy they keep getting
more and more away from physics
literally in fact in fact uh Max born
said uh uh physics has become more and
more abstract it turns out that abstract
is the opposite of physics yeah and so
uh we're getting away from physics and
we're into abstracts when you just
talked about the particle being not a
ball not a thing that's a vibration last
thing less thing by the year and now
you're saying even uh particle is just
an excitation yeah about excited States
an excited state that's also called
quanta so there's going to be a lot of
quanta this November when when the
states are excited uh anyways other
underlying Quantum fields which are more
fundamental than the particles again the
vibration of a field is what a particle
is the Quantum field of a particle is
what a functional of fields associated
with the particle great we learned a lot
okay so far away from Fizz yeah and what
they talk about is interactions as you
can see they talk about the interactions
and they represent them with Feynman
diagrams there you see one on the right
it's two electrons and uh gamma deer
that's uh light okay that's the photon
you can see the squiggly
line reference down below that's a
photon and okay we understand Photon
electron moves throws a photon at
another electron chases it away probably
or or or just the other Photon picks up
the light and recognizes the light great
no problem with light because it's a
push Force electromagnetism how about a
pull Force like the glue on okay let's
look at the glue on with the One of
These Fine and finan diagrams okay here
it is okay this comes from a thaw whose
Road says the vitamin diagram shows two
up quartz exchanging what a gluon okay
so we have the two quarks okay that's
the green going to blue and blue going
to Green okay and in between there's a
glue on that's uh sent okay or exchanged
you can say great what's the problem
with this well the problem here is the
following here we have that a glue on is
what keeps the quarks from leaving
the nucleus of the atom and they always
represent them with these bed springs
and you say okay I understand that you
know they the the course cannot leave
the proton or the neutron because
they're held together by bed sprays it
turns out that there are no bed springs
in the uh standard model of quantum
mechanics so uh what the gluon is really
a particle that's being thrown from one
Quark to the other like you see here
where they say it's being exchanged okay
so it's being exchanged and by throwing
a glue on not a not a bed Spring by
throwing a glue on how do you attract
another Quark how does one Quark attract
another Quark that's the question they
have to answer and they don't answer
they avoid that quiz they just they
throw the glue on and they say it
attracts great what was the mechanism
what's the physics that underlies hit
the ball and pulled the ball towards
exactly that's exactly what a glue on is
there's a ball that pulls
baseball's a pool yeah can you imagine
pitcher throwing the ball and attracting
the batter towards them hit him in the
head he goes
okay
though so what is qft quantum field
Theory here it is a Quantum field theory
is a theoretical framework that combines
classical field Theory special
relativity and quantum mechanics okay
great qft is what used in particle
physics to construct what physical
models of subatomic particles not very
well though physics particles uh you
know I can understand a field uh when
it's vibrating like the one below that
field we can all understand but you know
a field of numbers you know
and in condensed matter physics to what
construct models of Quasi or quasi
particles what are the Quasi particles
well they're a collection of particles
okay okay or a phenomena really
okay uh so they're what Collective
excitation what if someone said uh
quarks are attracted by magnetism
instead of gluons
they can say anything because they can
get away from murder the way they
explain it yeah but no but they don't
explain it and they don't care about not
explaining and say well we don't
understand if you don't understand
what's your theory so we don't have a
theory of physique we don't have
physical interpretations what we have is
mathematical descriptions which is not
the same as a physical
explanation and they dismiss that as
philosophy yeah well that's opinion it
seems like they just kind of give these
like crappy even they know that it's BS
for the peasants not not really I would
say it's half and half you'll find a lot
of them who actually believe that they
have an explanation they say yeah it
sounds right to me you know you throw
the glue on it attracts it does it
through negative momentum transfer or
whatever nonsense they come up with and
to them it's okay or like who was it uh
Victor stedner uh Professor who died a
couple years ago professor at Hawaii
University and he says you know to a uh
mathematical physicist meaning a
mathematician you know
um the particle coming back from time
you know it's not so weird for them they
accept that it changed their their
normal yeah it's like it's okay we can
deal with that okay so whatever
okay and uh so here uh we have what a
particle is according to Quantum
Mechanics what was it it
citation of a field local excitation
obviously we're not talking about the
entire universe which is a field you
know vibrating we're talking localized
vibration but also a field I don't know
what they're talking about they're
talking about a fabric well here you'll
see it I'll we've got it Illustrated
folks you wanted to know what a field is
uh what a particle is right here you'll
see it Illustrated for you there it is
that is a particle
yeah another one let me put over here
it's a lava lamp yeah what it is is all
those uh Fields little Fields vibrating
Fields they make up a particle so it's
an excited field the field is apparently
it's excited but what's exciting and all
those things whatever those things are
that's part of the field so it's excited
so now you know what a particle is no I
don't well that was it don't get the
challenge that's that even that's not
excited that's a balloons
inflating out of nothingness and then
deflating into nothingness that's what I
saw not citations yeah excitation is too
vague and no that that is even also true
according to Quantum Mechanics because
they say particles pop in from the void
in other words from the void they
acquire length width and height
suddenly called virtual particles then
immediately they go back to being
whatever space was you know based on a
bunch of particles void the void is a
bunch of particles and they call it
energy you know that's hidden in there
in the void
so we have this energy the concept
energy acquires length and high turns
into a particle momentarily to make the
virtual particle then it goes back to
being energy whatever energy is because
that's what space is and but that's
that's my that's what bothers me that
they create out of nothing they're
guiding yeah yeah they're they're there
and we need a particle here Boop here
you go if the if the Greeks Got Away
With It come on yeah no no but that's
that's really what I love most about
your theories because you just start off
from the get-go look nothing can turn
into something something can't turn into
nothing but the rest the rest comes off
of that really even even the Rope itself
and the thread and all that is really
just offshoots off of that basic
assumption nothing can turn into
something something can't turn into
nothing if you disagree with that go to
another school because that's as basic
as we're gonna get if you think
something can turn into nothing or vice
versa then we're gonna agree to disagree
yeah because that's just a fundamental
no it's not agree to disagree you put
them in The Nut House yeah but that's
what I mean get away from me because
there's nothing for us to talk about
don't touch that and just in case it
doesn't stop with Quantum the field
remember general relativity is a field
Theory and this is this is the field
space time if you ever wanted to see it
there it is there's your there's your
field that's a nice wallpaper though
yeah but see uh okay now the the canvas
there you know the
um the hammock uh the little lines the
little threads that's space and time
that you're staring at there so the only
question is what is the gray or darkest
stuff that forms backdrop to space and
time because you cannot say well no
because that's space all the voids we
cannot have space behind space because
the void makes things so so we've
already taken up space because that's
what uh the lines are the lines are
space and time and so we don't know what
the dark stuff that gives shape to the
shade to the lines that's the void of
the voice yeah so that part we don't
know they never identify that stuff and
we're still looking for answers that
seems like a basic thing that they never
really even asked the fact anytime they
show something there's always something
surrounding that thing
when you say okay this is space space
ends here okay then what's around space
or this is because they do go
mathematically yeah they don't
conceptually they don't visualize it
because there's nothing to visualize in
mathematical physics what are you going
to visualize uh Mass uh energy force you
can't visual at time you know there's
nothing to visualize maybe a clock maybe
they don't use their imaginations no no
because they can't because they're
they're dealing with mathematical
Concepts which they call mathematical
objects okay and they say well can you
visualize I mean I can visualize an
object such as a table can you visualize
a mathematical object such as force and
a guy says no I can't uh but let me show
you the equation or the numbers or
whatever no I don't want to see I want
to see what physical object I want to
see the cause the mechanisms well do you
think a lot of the like
hate that you get from physicist
physicists comes from the fact that they
work so hard to get the perfect uh
equation equation and you're just using
your imagination like what are we
kindergarten like you think you could
just come with your imagination and come
up with the right answer let me first
correct you they don't hate me they
absolutely love me
but seriously the fact that they're
trying so hard to do all these equations
with numbers which takes a lot of mental
energy and you just come with
imagination like you think you think
things can just be answered by
imagination well let's answer that
question what did Einstein say what did
fine fine
said the same thing one said if you
cannot explain it to a bar maid you
don't know it well enough and the Eliana
said if you cannot explain it to a 10
year old again you don't know it well
enough again or something along those
lines in other words physics is
kindergarten stuff an eight-year-old
should be able to understand physics
once we identify the invisible
intangible mediators that mother nature
uses as long as we're going to do it
with particles we're not going to be
able to answer any question because
Mother Nature cannot use particles we
cannot explain a single phenomenon like
gravity or any or magnetism with
particles so we should abandon the
particle the particle has been the
killer in that sense but if we replace
that with interconnectivity throughout
the Universe now we have a different
universe and now we can start explaining
it in terms that anyone can understand
including an eight-year-old boy but if
you're going to go in and explain what
particles and then say well I cannot
explain but let me show you the man the
kid said the eight-year-old says I
haven't take I haven't gone to I haven't
even taken algebra you know but it gets
frustrating as the as the questioner
because you'd never get your answer no
you don't you just never get an answer
and then you get shamed for being too
dumb to understand the so-called things
oh you're too dumb to understand it I'm
asking the wrong guy then
okay so what is a field officially okay
we gotta find an official definition for
field because these people say what's an
interaction and we must Quantum Field
hold on this is a vibration of a field
you can't even say official because
there's another one just kind of give
their own interpretation no no because
there is an official definition of the
word field for the purposes of
physically we need to put this up there
so that people can compare these these
other Notions that people have
interaction you know and the fact that
uh particle is the vibration of a field
and it's just a number you know what is
a field officially how is it defined how
is the word field defined okay and here
it is okay we have field a quantity okay
it's what does it feel equality we could
stop there with period right equality
that's what a field is what is it
represented by a number another quantity
that has a value another number all we
have is numbers values quantities
amounts okay for each point in space and
time what is the point well the point
it's misdefined as well it's an exact
location that's what a point is and it
has no length width and height no
kidding I mean if it's a location it's a
concert but had better not have length
with her height or you've drank too much
beer and then uh in space and time well
with a space well I like space space is
the fundamental space I love that one
that was a great definition out of the
Wikipedia and time well is to continue
blah blah blah blah blah past present
and future but past present and future
is a synonym of time you can't Define
past present or present or future
without the word time so all we have is
a synonym and what have we learned with
all this absolutely nothing and if
you're too dumb to understand it well
that's your problem right no no you
haven't gone to college well Timmy says
well I guess I'm never doing physics and
then he's out no but if he does
physically meaning mathematically yeah
then he gets brainwashed and says see
you you dumb maybe with the shame stick
and you're not gonna have a career stick
until you just nod your head you gotta
fall in line just say okay fine um yes
this is the way it is okay here my
conclusions okay what is a field is it's
defined as a bunch of numbers but field
is also widely treated as a thing field
is also said to be an interaction
whatever that is which means it's a verb
uh a particle is an excited field space
time is equivalent to a field so we have
no idea what a field is because it's all
these things all of the above okay so
yes field is a spirit whenever you use
the word field all you said is the word
Spirit you're doing uh traditional
religion by saying well it's really
scientific because we're using these
scientific terms okay and uh Quantum
loves Fields now they abandoned the
particle now they like Quantum field
Theory that's the it's more malleable
it's less it's more advanced no it's
more than that it's more you know what
it is it unifies the universe it says
that everything is really interconnected
this is the issue and there you see it
uh has abandoned the discrete particle
hypothesis and now proposes that all
particles are physically interconnected
in a grand web known as field
right so this is this is the issue the
issue is that now uh quantum mechanics
has moved it no longer is what it used
to be in the 1920s so maybe you were
left behind or whatever uh Quantum
doesn't deal with particles anymore
we're discrete particles which is the
way it started that's what Quantum
really meant you know they were dealing
with the quantum meaning a quantity
right localized quantity they
represented it with a ball with a point
a child of quantity but now they
represent it with a point but they they
qualify and they say well really it's
not a point it's not a little ball what
it is is the vibration and excited feel
that's what it is what's a field what's
this thing that extends like a web all
over the universe but locally it
vibrates and that's what we mistake for
a field as soon as we put our probes
there it turns into a particle because
we detect something and point-like and
we say okay that's a particle now as
soon as you take it out because you know
according to Quantum The Observer
affects the universe right so we put the
pros we turned it into a particle we
removed the probes it continues
vibrating as a localized field
that's what a field is I hope you
understood it all another thing that
bothers me about all that is
there there are other let's call them
like branches of science the way you
would call it science like I'm talking
about philosophers now who quote
physicists nowadays saying how the
Observer changes the experiment and
they're saying ah you see how
Consciousness is actually a physical
object that changes the universe because
as these guys are saying when you look
at something it changes how it behaves
no there's they're wrong too
yeah it's been scientifically proven
that our attention changes the universe
no it changes your subjective perception
it goes on and on and on everything they
stack BS on BS basically yeah and then
you lose track of where the BS started
okay let's move on to our science critic
we have uh one
discussion with this gentleman he made a
video 45 minute video and in it he
criticized a scientific method can you
believe that what did he criticize about
it well he criticized he says it's not
right
and we say you know the scientific
method is right uh except that maybe
he's got the wrong scientific method or
he should use the scientific method on
his theory yeah okay so today we're
going to discuss what he raised in his
uh video and that has to do with what an
object is and that is write down our
line of work here we love the word
object so here it is let me get it
rolling for you listen carefully here
goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
do synonyms qualify as definitions
RC and touch rational criteria to define
the word object for the purposes of
physics
so the definition that I found from
Googling is a material thing that can be
seen or touched however there is also
another definition that we will get to
later so I'd say that in both of those
examples they can be seen or touched
just not necessarily by you the
definition doesn't require that it has
to be seen or touched it just requires
that it can be
okay so
um the first thing I have to notice uh
from what he said I'll put here the
summary is that he's an expert at copy
paste I mean all he did was copy paste
from uh I guess the Google or from the
dictionary and we just put it up there
that's it they said that's what I found
uh he never thought that he could
criticize a definition that he could uh
change a definition or object to it and
say Hey you know that's not a rational
definition
and it's like you know uh
you wonder about these people it's like
they have just absorbed it's just
they're just memorizing stuff it's
poetry for them it just goes in one ear
and out the other he he just uh repeats
what he sees out there and that's bad
that's that's not the way we have to do
science if a definition if something is
broken you fix it if a definition is
wrong you fix it that's actually a good
point that a lot of people don't bring
it bring up the fact that some people
say see this is the definition of
whatever and it's like well yeah but
that's not how words work no we make up
our own definitions but they don't if
they're not serving the conversation
then we have to make up our own
efficient physics you can't just uh
bring indiscriminately from ordinary
speech words into physics and say well
that's what it says in the dictionary
that's when I copied and pasted it it
doesn't work that way you know if if if
it's wrong if it's irrational
and you want to bring it over no you
have to redefine it you have to redefine
it oh and if if you find something wrong
with it criticize it obviously you're
going to criticize it if you can't use
it in science and uh so that's one issue
definitions being up to debate that's a
big
big point the fact that a definition
isn't written in stone because if
someone comes to it we invent words yeah
yeah but if if two like even mainstream
physicists are on a stage with let's say
a religious person a religious person
defines God as that which exists already
he he introduces the word existence in
God's definition and by definition he
would exist right and so so that
definition would just Trump everything
he could just say whatever he wants
right just by the definition
words have to be very carefully uh
defined and that's one issue but the
other one is that you know these
mathematicians they call themselves
physicists scientists whatever they call
themselves and they always skip that
very important first step of the
scientific method which is make your
assumptions put your assumptions on the
line so that we can see your definitions
the objects you're going to use and your
initial scene and they skipped that step
they say well that's philosophy uh
that's semantics that's just word
sounded and they say let me tell you my
theory
you know they jump over the first step
of the scientific method and here we see
the point number two from this fall and
that's a material thing that can be seen
or touched okay uh material is already
the word that we're trying to Define
material is the word object more or less
and thing again he says material thing
and he didn't realize that thing is the
word we're trying to Define so it
doesn't even click in his brain he
doesn't have you know the mental
capacity to tie his shoes and chew gum
at the same time you know I mean this
this poor fella is really out of it and
he should have figured this out all by
himself but he doesn't he doesn't have
the intelligence for this then he's a
seed touch but you but not by you
oh then by whom I mean
you can see touching but I can't the
blind man can't see it so I like that
defense defining the negative not by so
by anyone else but that's exactly what
he said this is not a definition first
of all it's a proof okay you need to run
an experiment to do C or touch you know
you need to touch it and he says well
but it doesn't have to be by you okay is
the word table not an object until we
run the test
I mean the word table does it represent
an object or not he said well let me
touch it and I'll tell you that's that's
his answer or see it you know can you
touch the table you dreamed about last
night
well I tried to touch my brain but I
can't touch the table I dreamed about is
the word table an object or not
and so it depends on which table you're
talking about now yeah this is the issue
you can't touch the table on the other
side of the Universe on the other side
of the planet Etc and then the last one
he says can be it doesn't mean that it
has to be he says but it can be touched
well how do you know that you can touch
the table until you actually touch it
because it has the property with if you
if you click on properties if you right
click on it and open the properties tab
it says touchable Ah that's in
programming I'm talking about physics
and that program I don't know God knows
if you had God's programming yeah how do
you know you can touch it
I mean if I if I say hologram is a
hologram a physical object or not well
he says well you have to see or touch it
and I'm saying well can I touch it can I
see it maybe I can't even see it if I'm
blind right uh maybe I can't touch it
and does that make a hologram not an
object because uh it's missing the seat
touch criteria according to him not by
you so if I were to do this then it'd be
fine no he says you don't even have to
touch it or necessarily have to tell you
something
that it can be touched but unless you
touch it or see it you won't know that's
how they get around the Seer touch well
I'm not there well it's touch Hubble or
sea elbow well how are you supposed to
know this touch over this yeah
again for example I can give you another
example there's a light in the universe
right you just saw a light that's poetic
no no I'm saying suddenly there's a
flash of light somewhere a little dot
just illuminated in the in the sky was
that an object or was it not
well I could see it yeah okay what if it
didn't light up what if there's
something there you can't see obviously
you can't touch it right you say it can
be touched but you not necessarily have
to touch it you can see it but you're
not necessarily have to see it
well maybe there's nothing there maybe
there is something there what do I call
this x well all that just speaks to the
subjectivity of that criteria because if
if you're just having a bad day or if
you're drunk or something you just
happen to see something that doesn't
make that real that's that's something
in your brain because then you can't
tell if the object is that is there or
if it's in your brain and then it gets
into this weird
topic of who's seeing it who's touching
it okay let's get to some of the
questions people asked since last time
let me see if we can go through them
relatively quickly follow says what is E
equals m c squared or m equal well he
just turned him around according to
Einstein it is mass multiplied by the
speed of light squared flies really
humorous at the light speed squared
okay no no like he's saying light
squared speed of light squared y squared
I mean what does that mean that I'm
flying through the universe at the speed
of light we can all imagine but the
speed of light squared well what what
does that mean in physical term opacity
good question and so I can only show you
my universe interconnection right here
it is okay this is my interconnected
universe
and what you see here is that all atoms
are interconnected okay physically
interconnected we start out with two
atoms that are connected by the Rope
electromagnetic rope pair of twine
threads all the atoms are connected okay
and so our universe consists of this uh
you could think of them as galaxies as
atoms whatever you want to think of them
you know and essentially everything is
interconnected okay where is this
important uh for what this gentleman
asked okay so let's show the uh why it's
relevant okay and here we have it okay
we have the interconnected Universe we
look at the gravitational constant G and
it's got these strange unit Mass cubed
I'm sorry meter cube kilogram squared
second squared what the hell does that
mean well when we Factor uh all these uh
components uh we find that it's the mass
of the hydrogen atom and a little c
squared okay so here it is one more time
meter cubed over kilogram second squared
what the hell can that possibly mean in
physical terms and here we explain what
it means once we factor out the uh
components of the gravitational constant
T we find the mass of the hydrogen atom
and c squared c squared means that every
atom in the universe sends light to our
atom and our Target atom and our Target
atom sends light back to it
every right so that's what c squared
means in physical terms obviously uh
using Einstein's equation you'll never
figure it out with particles and that's
why they haven't figured out what the
gravitational constant G actually stands
for what it means in physical culture
the units what they mean that's that's I
like that because that's also not talked
about enough where there if you talk
about simple
physical equations when you have you
know cargos this many meters uh per
uh minute let's say or whatever you give
us some you know
some unit and you multiply that by two
everyone knows what's what the equation
how the equation translates to reality
if you multiply that by two you go okay
I know what's going on this car is going
twice as fast twice as fast right so
you're related to yourself exactly that
everybody can understand but when they
start getting even more and more
abstract c squared it gets it loses
track of reality and you're like what
what does this mean yeah that's just
that's just math what's the physical
interpretation of C squares that's the
thing everyone wants to that's really
what what physicists would love to see
people like you somehow turning their
equations into real physical like look
this number right here this is exactly
what's happening or the the reason why
this is
for this specific fraction is because of
this right and uh no they that's why
they like me they love me they don't hit
me you get it wrong you got these people
wrong because you're gonna make them
lose all their all their jobs okay it
says uh fellow says when we know
something it's not believe hypothesis or
Theory it is fact
when you know it's fact okay impurely
correct truth
we have truth fact not belief okay the
only barrier to truth truth okay is
believing
you already have it okay so the only
barrier is believing okay or that truth
is unobtainable okay our best route to
truth is the scientific method and uh
belief is accepting something is true
without evidence even if it's contrary
to Scientific Method okay so here are
the answers to he said a mouthful so we
we're gonna say a mouthful uh here here
are examples evidence for space-time
gravity Pro B frame dragging okay so we
do have evidence for space-time
according to the official version so is
it true fact right that the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
because space time is Warped
evidence for Big Bang galaxies are
running away from each other right
they're receding so is it true fact
right that matter surreptitiously
appeared without cause from the void at
the Big Bang
and evidence for black holes we have
some stars orbit around nothing that's
the official version okay so it's a true
fact that Zero D Singularity right
matterless Singularity pulls on matter I
really love that list because it really
breaks down the evidence for these
beliefs yeah maybe that you should you
should keep that frame it frame it yeah
because it it shows where these things
come from yeah
what are all these evidences at least
the establishment means that these are
evidence they put them as evidence for
the the rightfulness or the correctness
of general relativity well there you
have it okay all these evidence and if
that evidence proves a fact a truth
right and we've got proof now we've have
knowledge it's no longer belief then can
we explain all these things can we
explain that nothing came that something
came out of nothing during big bang that
a singularity zeros dimensional
Singularity volume less Singularity
matter less Singularity can pull on
something like a star and uh what was
the other one um uh I can't remember
well that would mean this but in that
case wouldn't some facts
uh cancel out other facts no but he's
talking about evidence he says yeah I
believe and I have evidence
can you you might believe this part but
then can you answer other questions
assuming you concede you know the these
uh evidence but that's what I'm saying I
think they would concede them be like
yeah that is a Zero Dimensional particle
is pulling on other things but then that
would cancel out the fact that only
things with masks can pull on other
things things with Dimensions but this
is this is result very easily and it's
been around for thousands of years or at
least hundreds of years and that is you
know the little B going around a flower
to some people proves that God exists
and that there is a God because only God
could have made something like that and
to other people they say well so much
evil in the world people are killing and
they're committing adultery and all this
other stuff that's there can't be a God
and so we have all these evidences for
one guy it's evidence that God exists or
the other one had ever evidence that God
does not and evidence for facts I.E
evidence evidence is a matter of opinion
if not go to a jury trial yeah you'll
learn real quick the same gun could be
used from the defenses
no no see that the reason that smoke is
coming out of the gun
that's who it is okay so another file
says words don't have intrinsic meaning
but instead a usage which might change
over time oh I like that yeah really
words change over time and so uh that's
true but but let me just say let me just
say the following now I'm going on that
one too okay so words change over time
but that's not the issue the issue is
that whoever is the theorist the guy
presenting a Theory of physics and a
physical interpretation he's got to
define the terms okay so if they don't
use the uh standard definition of
ordinary speech or even of mathematics
right and they bring it into physics and
they say this is the definition I'm
going to use and there's a problem with
it yeah right there and then we don't
care if um if he doesn't use the
standard definition or he does use it he
better be able to defend whatever
definition he puts for it but why
because we're really not interested in
the words we're more interested in the
notion or the I mean that's the best
word I can use yeah yeah it's the
meaning yeah the meaning behind the
words is it's hard to talk about that
because
we all have the same certain ideas and
we just the the word is the shorthand
for that so we don't have to say the
whole thing every time recite the whole
like if you want to talk about that
there's new ones yeah yeah we say
everybody understands something
different magnetism is shorthand for a
lot it's a lot packed within the word
magnetism so my magnetism doesn't
perfectly overlap with your definition
of magnetism so the reason we Define
words is so that so that you know
exactly what the boundaries of my
definition are so you can at least
accept that temporarily
they're all the same page so so anything
that falls outside of that is not
magnetism yeah it makes it very easy to
to talk another fella talks about
entangle man he says quantum
entanglement has been demonstrated
experimentally who has it okay the
utilization of entanglement and
communication blah blah blah in uh
technology essentially that's what he
says uh yeah the what is the problem the
problem is that we're not interested in
technology first of all and second it's
been demonstrated experimentally but
um all that they demonstrated something
here affects something over there we
still don't know how we don't know why
we don't know the cause we don't know
the mechanism that's the way the problem
is the problem is physics yeah and so
here we have nobody has ever seen an
electron oh this is a fella who answered
him I guess uh says nobody has ever seen
an electron nor a photon nor a neutrino
yet they can be entangled nobody ever
tells us how they achieve that
entanglement right this is the issue the
issues we need to figure out how it's uh
what the mechanism of entanglement is
the physical mechanism the particles are
mathematical abstractions of actions
conditions and locations absolutely
that's all they are quantum mechanics is
nothing more than a clever probabilistic
mathematical framework the math is
useful but has no bearing on reality
itself he said it he said everything
just perfectly so I had to put this
Fella's reply to this other gentleman
here
okay but yeah the issue is bottom line
is we have no explanation for how
entanglement works and you will never
figure out entanglement with particles
which is still what's out there even and
I'm saying even if you have field Theory
right what is what is a field okay let's
concede the field of quantum mechanics
which is a local excitation of a field
okay so we have a local excitation of a
field here and another excitation of a
field here these are particles yeah
these are particles this one's excited
this one's excited how does this one
affect that one
instantaneously which is you know they
measure and they say it goes faster than
light which violates special relativity
by the way I guess uh that's another
point but tell me the mechanism how does
this one affect that one that's all you
got to say
okay
okay uh here's another gentleman he says
when someone says Rock I comprehend very
well what he she is talking about and
further information about the size
density Etc will increase accuracy of my
comprehension just like it would when
someone says I saw a film okay now in
science we do not comprehend rocks okay
it doesn't work that way uh rock is
something you visualize so we do not use
the word comprehend comprehend is what
we use for theories for a movie you say
I comprehend the movie I know what it
was about uh so Concepts is what we
comprehend but when you talk about
things like a rock you don't comprehend
them you you point to them and name them
and illustrate them well you teach the
language to your to the Klingon that's
what you do you could with words
describe it better like with more words
yeah but not necessary up front High
Point table you don't say I comprehend
the table unless it's really important
that that rock has like a certain Groove
into it or something like okay but
specifically about this rock it's got
into it but even then it's in Congress
language to use the word comprehension
comprehension it's very visualizing
better if any so so when you bring that
word comprehend into science that's
where we're making the distinction in
ordinary speech you can say whatever you
want when you bring it into science we
don't say we comprehend rock you say
this is a rock I name it I point to in
the guy says okay I see what you're
talking about I visualize it in fact
once the guy knows what a rock is you
just mention the word Rock and the guy
already visualizes it that's not
comprehension that's called visualizing
rocks we visualize Concepts we
comprehend okay and especially
comprehension really has to do more with
something elaborate a movie you have
something it's got to be a theory uh uh
uh process yeah a process a tale you
know anything that's lengthy that's what
you comprehend you don't say you
comprehend Rock
okay
uh I fellow says God is the perfect
concept and is the perfect object guy
who wants God to be both object and
concept I had these before but I'd
rather use the word person well person
is an object a thing
okay
so uh I mean if if you can draw a person
you know and you say a person then it's
a thing now if you use the word person
as a concept which is a possibility
depending on the context that's
something else but uh the word person
usually refers to people because you're
referring to a human to a dude I mean
you don't call a lion a person
is the word we use for people and if uh
God is people God is object okay and so
that's how simple it is here's a model
of all our Concepts and objects but he
is none of them himself himself I like
them
we know he hasn't seen so now we know
yeah he's uh very important that he has
a we which creates an illusion of his
absence whatever that meant we can
describe all Concepts at least I don't
understand it we can describe all
consequences of his evidence of his
existence but not him personally okay if
he's a him he's an object period we're
done he's not a concept and he has male
genitalia yeah
at least we know to him
very important man to make a macho you
know okay
and another fellow he says the father
says an insect walking on a perfect
sphere does not know what a sphere that
a sphere is infinite yeah uh this comes
from the finite and unbounded phrase
that they use in general relativity and
in mathematics right Finance but
unbounded what does that mean they say
look an object you know here you have an
object okay
it's finite right because it it has a
surface okay and what they when they use
the word unbounded they're referring to
something else okay they say if you roll
around the ball the little ant going
around the ball right then
um you know you can move on forever so
it's unbounded they're using an
adjective as an adverb they should say
look you can walk eternally you can walk
constantly you can walk incessantly but
you cannot say I walk unboundedly
because the object is not infinite but
you can walk around it infinitely you
know that's a wrong usage of an
adjective what you're doing is referring
to two different things the object is
fine up but you're saying that you can
walk infinitely yeah so is it finite or
infinite well it's both they say because
see it's finite but unbounded no no
what you have to say is but I can walk
infinitely around it then people would
understand and they're really correct
way to say is I can work eternally uh
incessantly around it you have to use an
advert not an adjective this is where
the problem is
okay and here's another fella and this
one made me laugh uh follow says that is
correct the number lines don't have
orthogonality you know you cannot have a
number line perpendicular to another
number line because numbers have no
Direction even if they're in series they
have no Direction but the file says but
different units units like you know five
pounds or whatever that can be counted
on a number line do have orthogonality
right
yeah he blew me away with that too huh
for example look at this the amount
right is per orthogonal to the amount
foreign
the amount of windshield wiper fluid in
my core is orthogonal to the amount of
oil in my car so so he's saying that uh
the amount is orthogonal to the amount
well he blew me away I I haven't drank
enough beer to understand that so I'm
talking about like on a graph like if
you want to know how much
one pipe has oil the other one has gas
and he says well the oil is
perpendicular to the gas I don't know
but a lot of answers that you get like
these are so non-specific where it's
kind of like when you used to write
books and I'd edit them you know what
you were talking about but as an outside
of me reading I'd be like yo but you're
missing a lot of words here for normal
people understand I think everyone needs
an editor are you saying that I'm not a
normal people no I'm saying everyone has
that problem where everyone thinks that
they know what they're talking about
yeah and they write it down because they
know what they mean but then when
someone else reads it they're like well
you're missing that's why people people
have to ask questions because you know
sometimes you say well I I thought I
said everything property so that
everybody understood but then people
started asking questions oh they didn't
understand stand this they didn't
understand that that's when you realize
that there's a lot of stuff that people
don't take for granted as you do when
you're speaking Yeah that's a big one
okay and the last one we have this uh
fellow and he says the following he says
Adams never have to Traverse through
perpendicular ropes as they slide down
well you know um they do as you can see
we have two situations here the first
one uh right in the white region there
the uh atoms in the hand are moving
along or you know they're moving along
or you can say the the atoms itself are
moving along the wire or the the Rope
the Rope which it's moving towards
another atom that connects them to
another atom so in that case it doesn't
cross any atom any Rogues but the atom
that the one on the bottom the hand goes
right through the Rope so it does move
in that sense perpendicular to the
direction you have a rope moving
indicative to that rope on the bottom
and the hand is moving right there right
across the Rope so it does move
perpendicular to the rope and let me
give you another example let me give you
another example just so you can see here
this is a Hands-On one so uh we'll do
this
you know here you have a magnet okay
uh can you hold those two okay and you
get them together
and show them a stick okay so the
magnets attract now I'm going to pass my
hand right through the threads that are
in there and there are also ropes from
everywhere in the universe crisscrossing
right in front of us and I'm moving my
hand right through all those ropes all
those threads so uh this is like a
seriously yeah so to say that the hand
does not move perpendicular to ropes uh
and that the hand doesn't cross yeah I
disagree I think uh hands do cross
the ropes every every day going right
through the ropes yeah somebody ropes
crisscrossing this room alone yeah uh
we're crossing ropes and if you just
count one atom on one edge of the
universe to the other that's just
cutting through so much yeah and and
remember uh how can we get away with
that well why don't we get tangled well
because the ropes are intangible and
invisible so don't go out there and run
an experiment to try to say well what
experiment can I run to detect the Rope
you will not detect a rope it it is
suggested that it has this architecture
and nothing else that's the only
commonality you can say that it has with
a Ropo that you buy at the hardware
store otherwise it's invisible and
intangible okay and so it has the
architecture of a rope in that invisible
intangible world of Mother Nature and
with it
we can explain
many things in physics
without uh we have any questions well we
got a lot of comments Bill how is
Frankfurt I always loved that City
Frankfort is doing fine today we had
rain so not great at all in that sense
you know and I think some of the weather
here affects my joints maybe I don't
know I suspect you'll get there is field
an object or a concept well obviously
it's a concept because uh field first of
all field has something in motion inside
it matter in motion if it has matter in
motion obviously you have two
okay because you're talking about these
two frames of the universal movie
whenever you have two objects in this
case one object of two locations which
is the same thing whenever it embodies
or uh in some way the word uh in
embodies or invokes two objects you have
a concept so field is always a concept
do you ever use the word feel like
magnetic field or you just talk about
areas or what do you how do you use well
I use the word field only to refer to
what the establishment the universe yeah
I I only use it in terms of relating to
the establishment otherwise uh only and
maybe as a shorthand you know I say
we're talking about the field so that
you say okay I'm referring to what's
between these two magnets but I don't
use the word feel like saying the field
did this the field did that no that
that's when I come back with my threads
and say look if we're talking about a uh
magnetic field threads if we're talking
about uh gravitational field we're
talking about ropes
Bill who sabotaged the Nordstrom
pipeline
I don't know
again remember uh this war that's going
on over there um
[Music]
we don't know enough of what's going on
because uh on this side of the uh
dividing line right we get uh the news
that people over here want to give us
and on that side the poor Russians are
receiving whatever their government
gives us you know you have all these
mafias and they just give whatever
information they want uh to their own
people because it's got very little to
do by the way with freedom of speech or
freedom of the press on both sides it's
got to do with military operations
whenever you have military operations
you the military have learned over the
years that you must control the
information for two reasons one you
don't want to give the other side
information that you know for free and
let them do their own spying you know
that's one issue the other one is you
want to get your people on your side and
say hey we're winning the war look how
many we're killing over there and it
turns out you're losing miserably but
you're not going to tell that to your
people because they lose Faith so it's
got to do with military operations and
politics not with freedom of speech uh
it's not what the person asked but a
better question a better version uh
could the speed of light be conceived as
not being a constant
well under the Rope model it is a
constant we agree with Mr Einstein not
only that we agree that it's got a speed
limit and we also agree that
um when an object when you turn your
flashlight on the train you don't add
the speed of the train to the flashlight
okay and so we're saying that the only
way you can really explain all that is
with this you have a rope okay and you
can see how many links there are for
this you know it's a finite rope okay so
for whatever length of rope this is I
have so many links if I un-torque it the
links become longer and I have fewer
links and if I torque it more I have
more links and each link is shorter so
all we have in the tiny letter c 300 000
kilometers per second is a change beat
an exchange you know an inverse relation
between uh frequency and wavelength
that's all we have
uh light always travels at the same
speed between any two atoms at least in
this part of the universe maybe we get
to the edge of the universe somewhere
out there maybe there's a different
speed for whatever reason okay that's
for some follow more intelligent than me
to figure out
is time dilation effect
well time dilation uh depends on what we
call a fact I mean time dilation is a
fact in the sense that
um if you take an atomic clock and you
take it farther out into space it runs
at a different speed than the one down
here okay likewise if you take a uh you
know what I call a uh sand clock you
know an hourglass you take it out there
it also runs at a different speed but in
the opposite direction to an atomic
clock so which clock should we rely on
the gravitational clock called an
hourglass or an electrical clock uh
called an atomic clock well it doesn't
matter you know because obviously
they're in opposite directions so
Einstein did not show that time dilation
is universal in the way that he thought
it was meaning that time goes uh slower
or faster out there now it depends on
what clock you have that's one issue the
other one is uh you know the issue of
the in relation to the twin paradox time
dilation they say well you know the
traveling twin he travels close to the
speed of light around a black hole and
then comes back well he doesn't age
because time went a lot
um slower for him right and faster for
the guy here on Earth but it turns out
that you know we don't count the number
of uh years that went by uh with clocks
okay the way we count the candles on
your cake is with a number of orbits
around of the Earth around the Sun and
so when the prevalent twin comes back
either 20 years went by or two years
went by a lot of people yeah and for
both the sun didn't go more times for
one guy
so that's physics and all the other
stuff is math you know calculation they
say oh look at the calculation now uh
again the clocks travel at different
speeds at different distances from the
earth well uh Mercury I'm sorry uh Mars
travels at different speed with respect
to the Sun
uh compared to the um to the Earth so
that means people age faster yeah so so
people in Mars uh They Live Twice as
much you know
what does that tell us that's all
okay folks we'll see you next Sunday and
uh we'll see you then bye bye thanks
guys